Benghazi 2015 and the rebels who
spearheaded Libya's revolution are now
fighting Islamic state extremists
they're part of the East operation
dignity their commander is general
Hefner who was once Colonel Gaddafi's
chief of staff slowly bit by bit
afters army is taking back control of
the city most synonymous with the Libyan
Revolution the suggestion is they're
getting outside help with arms and
weapons from authorities like those in
power in Egypt who have a similar
anti-islamist anti-muslim Brotherhood
agenda general hafta has the Americans
and Washington's confidence to the
Pentagon this week announced its first
strike inside Libya since the Revolution
four years ago
but despite the external support the
internationally recognized government is
confined to here in the east of Libya
the anarchy has divided the country and
allowed the Islamic state and criminal
gangs to flourish it's still not sure
where the highest militants are that's
why they're using this big weaponry
they're worried about rooting them out
because they think they're hiding in
various buildings still further down
they trace one group to a building just
a few hundred meters away from their own
position they would train and why does
he think they're still here because
they're quite outnumbered now in this
particular area
I seem to stay until they die the
Islamic state still has its strongholds
of Derna and cert from where the
extremists have posted images of
multiple beheadings but Benghazi is key
you think two to three months before
Benghazi is yes
Benghazi is the most of them after
soldiers view him as the potential
savior of a fractured Libya the general
in the light colored cap on the east
front lines some months ago is seen as a
man of unrivaled military experience but
his war against the Islamists has led to
a big increase in his influence and the
rise of even a former Gaddafi man has
sent shudders down many Libyan spines
this is most keenly felt in the West in
Tripoli
where the rival government is on the
brink of bankruptcy the Capitals martyrs
square where they once excitedly
celebrated the downfall of a dictator is
now regularly filled with mourners
Libyans killed by Libyans in their civil
war the beaches of Tripoli are packed
yet this is a city abandoned by most
embassies because of fear of kidnappings
and the absence of law and order and
where human trafficking has flourished
in Libya's power vacuum the Prime
Minister based in the capital is not
acknowledged internationally his enemies
say his administration is Islamist and
weak and exactly why is or - is
operating unbridled here
[Music]
what will heed our mooshka where he is
he sir no I have to Yetta Raja
well Libya now fizzles our what our
bodies are salomina why how could never
count it of course general hiftar says
you you are this is an Islamist
administration and this is part of the
problem this is why - is thriving here
I'm sorry this is what they say after a
woman you Leela she lets not the only
Harbor - what have you no learning curve
in Nomos the moon not America where they
can howler libera about an hour's drive
from Tripoli in Zawiya hidden far away
from the beaches and businesses are some
of the human cargo who are making
smugglers millions Libya's Kaos gave
them that opportunity with militia
criminal gangs and is all making a
financial killing out of their misery
ten days before we got here armed men
took away 300 of these locked up
migrants all thought they were is come
to snatch the migrants in order to
secure the next payment for their
smuggling route into Europe gonna like
to eat that he he's hearing all the
panic about - so when he saw the black
the black mass that's all he could think
of yeah that's all he could think of
those left behind bitterly regret not
going even if it meant handing
themselves over to the extremists do you
wish you'd gone now do you wish you had
gone with them yeah why not
what can I do 40 days I was here what
can I do I have to change my family
you all right you all right
I'm with my family : oh no I mean they
don't know even we are dating now they
are non people with no one claiming
responsibility for them and the country
unable to cope
Alex Crawford Sky News Libya